هذا المبنى المكون من 14 طابقا طبعا هذا
الحديث كان قبل الزلزال الان سوي بالارض
ما زال تحت الانقاذ تحت الانقاض هناك
احياء لذلك تتسارع وتيره الاعمال هنا
للوصول الى
الاحياء هنا سيحاول زميلي طبعا رصد المشهد
عن قرب طبعا كنا تحدثنا في النشرات
السابقه ان فرق الانقاذ سمعت اصوات
الاشخاص الموجودين او بعض اصوات الاشخاص
الموجودين تحت هذا المبنى لكن سمعوا
الاصوات مرتين لكن فيما بعد غابه الاصوات
لذلك تم استقدام فريق متخصص مع مزود
باجهزه حديثه ايضا وكلاب مدربه ابعد كل
الموجودين خارج هذا الموقع ومن ثم الفريق
تقريبا لمده نصف ساعه ظل يراقب المكان
ويتفحص الاماكن المتوقع ان يتواجد الاشخاص
او السكان الذين كان موجودين في هذا
المبنى وهم احياء النقاط التي كانوا
يتواجدون فيها وبالفعل تم تحديد بعض
النقاط واعادوا الفريق وبدا الحفر في تلك
النقاط وازالوا قسم من الركام طبعا
العمليه ميسون نحن نتحدث ونراقب هذه
العمليه منذ سبع او ثمان ساعات العمليه
معقده جدا لا يمكن الحفر بشكل عشوائي ولا
يمكن
العمل بدون اشراف في هذا المبنى ام لا
معلومات حول ذلك
نعم سالت الطواقم كم شخص يتوقعون انه يوجد
تحت الانقاض لا معلومات لديهم لكن يؤكدون
ان هناك اصوات تصدر وطالما ان هناك
العمليات ستستمر لا توجد اي احصائيه
حاولنا ان نبحث هنا في هذه المنطقه عن
اقارب او اشخاص كانوا موجودين هنا في هذا
المبنى لكن علمنا ان السلطات اجلتهم جميعا
الى مراكز ايواء لكن سيده واحده اقتربت من
كانت تتحدث مع الشرطه قالت ان اخيها كان
ما زال موجودا تحت الانقاض لا حاولنا
التحدث معها لكن الشرطه ابعدت ابعدتها
وابعدت ابعدت طبعا الجميع المكان هنا
محظور على المدنيين فقط فرق الانقاذ وطبعا
الصحفيين هنا خشيه من اي انهيارات لان
المباني المجاوره فيها تصدعات لذلك هذه
المنطقه محظوره تماما على المدنيين طبعا
كما ذكرت يعني المشهد هنا مشابه للمشهد
عند زميلنا عمار في هاتاي او في بقيه
المناطق المنكوبه